[Musica]
buonasera danilo gasparini insegno
storia del cibo dell'alimentazione dove
mi chiamano in realtà e si vede anche un
film molto importante sono un prodotto
interno lardo molto importante quello
che voglio raccontarvi oggi in termini
appunto di innovazione tradizioni radici
è legato al cibo
io partirei da alcune constatazioni di
tipo così molto generale se dico a voi e
uno di voi sei un tradizionalista
coltivi la tradizione non è che veicolo
dei valori straordinari
anzi è sinonimo di vecchio è sinonimo se
volete di statico di poco dinamico di
ottuso e chiuso e quindi parlare di
tradizione e generalmente noi veicoliamo
spesso e volentieri questa immagine
eppure quando noi parliamo di altri
settori che non sia il mio che è quello
del cibo si dà per scontato che innovare
è bello ogni economia
innovare è bello tutte le scienze
innovare bello della società innovare è
bello anche nella morale ma quando
affrontiamo invece un tema come come
quello del cibo dell'alimentazione apple
i abbiamo siamo un po sospettosi
cominciamo ad arricciare il naso
cominciamo avere dei sospetti su quella
che è la cucina innovativa non sempre
siamo d'accordo e tra trasliamo questa
sorta di valori da negativi e positivi
per quanto riguarda il cibo e qui ci
costruisce poi tutta una grande retorica
per cui allora bisogna difendere la
tradizione bisogna difendere i cibi
tradizionali bisogna difendere i
prodotti entrati giornali bisogna
difendere i piatti della tradizione
della cucina bisogna promuovere bisogna
promuovere il territorio
a volte penso che insegnando
il territorio magari qualche volta non
ricche di essere promosso
magari rimandato a settembre come si
faceva una volta
allora mi domando a mi sono chiesto
perché quando noi ragioniamo attorno al
cibo ragioniamo appunto attorno ai
piatti alla nostra cultura alimentare
siamo così radicati ci costruiamo su
feste ci costruiamo un sacco di eventi
abbiamo costruito perfino pensate delle
confraternite attorno al cibo fino agli
anni 50 l confratello intera quella del
santissimo sacramento della maria
ausiliatrice
adesso abbiamo la confraternita della
patata abbiamo la confraternita del
prosecco del basilico e celebriamo
grandi riti prendendo a prestito riti di
tutti i tipi e la tradizione è presente
nella nostra vita della nostra storia
oggi è san martino ed è tradizione
festeggiare questa questo santo che è
legato al ciclo agricolo
allora la domanda è cos'è che fa sì che
noi appunto radichiamo nel cibo e
nell'alimentazione un valore così forte
da farci resistere ed essere resistenti
da fare a volte per cui ho assistito a
casi un cui non so se si è andati dal
notaio o depositare la ricetta di un
piatto oppure sappiamo che la cucina da
che mondo è mondo è una cucina dinamica
contaminante non c'è quanto la cucina il
mondo alimentare che si contamina siamo
contaminati essere ripercorriamo la
storia evidentemente questo è evidente
noi è vero che siamo quello che mangiamo
ma spesso e volentieri mangiamo anche
quello che si ama e io vorrei a
raccontare appunto per arrivare a
concludere poi che la tradizione siamo
noi alla tradizione e oggi alla
tradizione del futuro partendo da uno
dei grandi prodotti
e la tradizione ho portato qui una fetta
di polenta per i veneti per il mondo
trevigiano evidentemente questo è un
cibo sacro
c'è uno stereotipo poi voi sapete veneti
polentoni e ci si vergognavano un po in
giro per il mondo quando ci dicevano dei
veneti pò lento dei poi c è chi faceva
anche un po di pausa un po lentoni poi
c'è quel proverbio che ci accompagna
ormai da secoli che ci da l'idea di cosa
di cosa pensano hanno pensato dei veneti
pensate ve lo dico in dialetto
trevigiano poi magari lo come lo potete
fare la traduzione simultanea meo punta
senza niente che niente senza polenta è
tradotta un meglio punto polenta senza
niente che niente senza polenta ma cos'è
che fa sì che a un certo punto quando
mangio polenta io non difendo una
tradizione e mi sento legato una
tradizione straordinaria e quando mangio
delle tortillas questa tradizione non
c'è più scelta solo un po esotico se
mangio le tortillas strambo o i tacos
eppure alla base di questi due di questi
due cibi c'è una materia prima che è
identica che ha il mais ai tacos e
legata alla the un sit e mona vedete ma
questo è l'antenato del mais
fate conto 6 milani avanti cristo nero
america da questo da questa te un sit e
siamo arrivati a questa un po di storia
è arrivata ma la cosa curiosa è che
quando questa pianta arriva da noi non
si porta dietro il modo in cui la
mangiavano in mesoamericane naso
americani non facevano polynt allora
l'ho mai fatta mangiavano tortillas
mangiavano tags il mais arriva qui voi
sapete con il viaggio di cristoforo
colombo che andava in cerca di tante
altre cose
andiamo in cerca delle spezie in realtà
e sia trovato il tacchino si è trovato
il cioccolato si è trovato tante cose
quando arriva evidentemente cosa succede
che il mondo padano il mondo vento
prende questa farina nuova la
sostituisce con delle altre farine prima
mangiava era abituato mangiato il
volontario del ponente se volete di
milio di sorgo di tante cose
la sostituisce ed è un'innovazione non è
una rivoluzione non cambia niente ha
trovato un prodotto nuovo importante che
lo sa di più e questa è un'invenzione
straordinaria perché permette ai veneti
di scollinare le grandi crisi di fine
cinquecento permette di scollinare
appunto le carestie permette anche ahimè
nel corso dell'ottocento di far sì che
molti contadini veneti ammalati di
pellagra abbiano a pagare un prezzo alto
per mangiare solo polenta cosa succede
allora un certo punto quando noi
recuperiamo la polenta a partire
soprattutto dalla dagli anni settanta
ottanta quando adesso mangiamo una
polenta
abbiamo sostituito quei valori o
disvalori se volete perché a quell'epoca
si mangiava polenta per necessità per
fame non per scelta
c'era quella a quel punto io sostituisco
quei valori perché non ho più la
necessità di mangiarla con altri valori
che sono i valori dell'identità io leggo
a un cibo dei valori di identità forte
perché se mangia una mela non faccio una
tradizione in gesto di tradizione è pure
alla vela è presente ad adamo ed eva è
andata così quella volta che si è eva
avesse detto ad adamo spaten tu prenditi
tula mila il destino delle donne sarebbe
stato molto diverso non avrebbero dovuto
preparare i piatti ancora oggi essere
schiave della cucina spesso e volentieri
perché la polenta perché allora attorno
alla polenta ci sono evidentemente dei
valori di identità fortissimi perché
oggi mangiare la polenta significa un
cibo di convivialità sono nate le feste
della polenta il festival della polenta
è nata anche un'associazione
straordinaria i polentari d'italia
pensate carlo marx
che diceva proletari di tutto il mondo
unitevi adesso polentari di tutta italia
unitevi perché poi l'abbiamo esportata
in brasile la down asportata in sardegna
le abbiamo esportato un po dappertutto
questo per dirvi che la tradizione è
dinamica io di volta in volta riempio
questo questo cibo con questo caso ma
tanti altre cose di valori nuovi a
questo punto
no ho dimenticato quei secoli ho
dimenticato tutte le tragedie legate e
lo riempita di cose nuove e attorno a
questa ho inventato altre cose per
ritornare a quello che si diceva in
questo punto avete visto qua più screw
cous cous e meno polenta e prima più
polenta e meno cous cous
ma sono d'accordo perché il cous cous
tutto sommato è la polenta del
mediterraneo allora a questo punto il
messaggio che io voglio dare proprio
questo la tradizione è un'invenzione si
rinnova sempre e dinamica non si ferma
mai
proprio nel mondo del cibo e nel mondo
della cucina la tradizione siamo noi
avete presente una pianta visto che si
parla di radici noi di una pianta alle
radici non le vediamo e vediamo solo il
frutto è più larghe sono le radici più
la pianta in grado di fare di produrre
dei frutti nuovi
ecco noi siamo il frutto di una pianta
che aden tante radici basta saperlo e
non aver paura del nuovo non aver paura
del nuovo anno aver paura di innovare
per noi poi per i veneti per i
trevigiani il cibo è un valore
straordinario traina traina tante cose e
quindi se noi abbiamo la minima
coscienza cioè quando mettiamo in bocca
un pezzo di polenta mettiamo in bocca
cinque secoli di storia mettiamo in
bocca tragedie ma l'abbiamo riempito di
cose nuove
credo che questa sia un grande passo
perché siamo noi che facciamo la storia
anche come mangiamo
allora io concludo dicendo voi guardate
buona polenta a tutti quanti e
soprattutto speriamo che sia veneta in
un solo grazie ea presto
[Applauso]